mais chers collègues nous avons le
plaisir d'accueillir aujourd'hui en
visioconférence monsieur José Bové
ancien député européen ancien
porte-parole de la Confédération
paysanne monsieur Beauvais merci d'avoir
accepté de répondre à nos questions et
l'invitation de notre commission
d'enquête parlementaire je vous prie de
nous excuser pour le retard de cette
début de commission et de l'attente que
vous avez eu monsieur Beauvais nous
sommes vraiment heureux de pouvoir vous
entendre je ne vous cache pas que le
bureau de notre commission a motivé
votre audition par un fait très précis
le 16 décembre dernier au micro de
France Inter quelques jours après la
révélation de la fête du cathargate vous
avez appelé l'antenne de la radio en
direct et vous avez affirmé avoir été
victime d'une tentative de corruption de
la part des autorités marocaines alors
que vous étiez rapporteur pour la
Commission du commerce international du
Parlement européen sur le projet
d'accord de libre-échange matière
agricole entre l'Union européenne et le
Maroc suite à cette interpellation
publique et à l'information
que vous avez donné aux auditeurs et ce
faisant au français nous avons estimé
qu'il était très important de vous
entendre sur cette mauvaise expérience
et d'une manière générale sur la bonne
expérience aussi que vous avez des
institutions européennes de la politique
française et des tentatives ou des
réalités d'ingérence qui peuvent la
frapper vous savez monsieur Beauvais que
c'est l'objet de notre commission
d'enquête parlementaires étudier et
avoir à connaître des tentatives ou des
réalités d'ingérence étrangères sur
notre démocratie et c'est relais nous
serions donc heureux monsieur Beauvais
que vous puissiez apporter toutes les
précisions possibles sur cet épisode qui
nous paraît particulièrement grave et
dont nous avons d'ailleurs du mal à
comprendre pourquoi il n'a pas été porté
plus tôt sur la place publique ce qui
aurait peut-être pu vous nous en direz
davantage servir à mieux protéger les
institutions européennes d'une part mais
surtout les institutions françaises et
notre démocratie
cette audition monsieur Beauvais je le
précise et retransmise en direct sur le
site de l'Assemblée nationale
l'enregistrement vidéo sera ensuite
disponible à la demande elle est ouverte
naturellement à la presse vous aurez la
parole monsieur le député pour une
intervention luminaire d'une quinzaine
de minutes puis nous poursuivrons nos
échanges avec les questions de votre
serviteur de madame la rapporteur
constance le rip et des commissaires
présents je vous rappelle monsieur
Beauvais cot titre de l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement de nos
assemblées parlementaires les personnes
auditionnées par une commission
d'enquête doivent prêter le serment de
dire la vérité toute la vérité rien que
la vérité aussi monsieur Beauvais je
vous invite à distance à lever la main
droite et à dire je le jure
je le jure je vous remercie je vous
laisse la parole pour votre introduction
alors d'abord bonjour merci d'accepter
de m'entendre
de cette manière à distance je sais que
c'est pas forcément le plus facile pour
vous mais en tout cas je vous en
remercie
on va commencer par le point que vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure c'était ma
prise de parole le 16 décembre
2022 à France Inter le matin
j'ai décidé de prendre la parole ce
jour-là pour revenir
sur cette tentative effectivement
de m'offrir entre guillemets un cadeau
à Montpellier
c'était au moins de juillet
2012 et à ce moment-là
c'était le ministre de l'Agriculture
monsieur akanouche
ministère et culture en titre du Maroc
qui m'avait proposé d'abord oralement à
Bruxelles puis ensuite par téléphone
qu'on se retrouve à Montpellier dans un
lieu
qui pouvait être un restaurant un café
un hôtel donc un lieu plutôt discret où
on pouvait discuter à la fois du fond et
en même temps de sa proposition
je lui ai donné une adresse le lendemain
ou le surlendemain et l'adresse que je
lui ai indiquais
il m'a répondu certainement avec l'aide
de ses services que ils ne connaissait
pas de restaurants d'hôtel ou de lieux
discrets dans cette rue de Montpellier
et je lui ai dit que ce rendez-vous
aurait lieu chez mon avocate maître
brasse et donc en sa présence et ça a
donné il a coupé court le téléphone
s'est arrêté et on en est resté là
j'ai raconté ce fait tout l'ensemble de
la discussion sur la corde de
libre-échange dont on va évidemment
reparler dans un ouvrage qui est paru en
alors j'essaie de vous le mettre comme
ça
à côté de moi voilà ça s'appelle hold-up
à Bruxelles
et le sous-titre les lobbys au cœur de
l'Europe cet ouvrage dans cet ouvrage
raconte ses faits et à ce moment-là
aucune poursuite de la part de ministre
d'agriculture marocain ou des autorités
marocaines a lieu
il faut attendre un an pour qu'une
journaliste du Nouvel Observateur
reprennent
cette affaire et se retrouve elle
poursuivie par les autorités marocaines
et
condamné devant le tribunal de Paris
pour ma part à ce moment là je ne suis
même pas cité à comparaître ni comme
témoins ni comme prévenu il faudra donc
attendre le mois de décembre 2022 pour
que cette affaire surgisse comme vous
l'avez signalé au moment du débat sur le
scandale du du coatergate et du Maroc
Gates pour que l'affaire revienne et que
je m'exprime à ce moment-là le ministre
de l'Agriculture du Maroc qui est devenu
entre-temps Premier ministre du Maroc et
qu'il est donc aujourd'hui encore avec
le soutien de son avocat annonce qu'il
va porter plainte contre moi pour
diffamation
nous sommes aujourd'hui donc le 4 mai il
avait trois mois pour saisir le tribunal
ce qui n'a pas été fait et donc
l'annonce qu'il a fait dans les jours
qui ont suivi mon intervention sur
France Inter et bien évidemment sont
éteintes dans la mesure où il n'a pas
donné suite et que à ce jour il avait
trois mois donc jusqu'à la mi-mars pour
pouvoir le faire il ne l'a pas fait on
est presque 5 mois après donc les
annonces faites à ce moment-là était en
fait des annonces je dirais de pure
forme mais
[Musique]
l'avocat de du Premier ministre du Maroc
est revenu sur cette affaire en imposant
un démenti dans lesquels les affaires
étaient rappelés au journal Le Canard
enchaîné et dans lequel ils ont mis il y
a d'ici un mois à peu près il y a à peu
près à moins de cela à nouveau une
ambiguïté en disant que tous ceux qui
avaient parlé de cette affaire là et
donc sans me citer j'ai été directement
visé
avait été poursuivi et condamné donc je
tenais à dire cela dans un préliminaire
dans la mesure où c'est quelque chose
qui à mon avis est important à signer à
signaler de mon point de vue
donc voilà pour le je dirais le
l'affaire qui m'amène aujourd'hui devant
vous et donc je réitère une fois de plus
la véracité de ces éléments et
donc je suis je maintiens ce qui s'est
passé alors le contexte de cette affaire
c'est l'accord de libre-échange sur
l'agriculture entre l'Union européenne
et le Maroc je suis nommé rapporteur de
ce dossier le 27 septembre 2010 devant
la commission INTA la commission INTA
étant la Commission du commerce
international du Parlement européen à ce
moment-là
la Commission européenne a fait une
proposition
d'accord
qui va être validé très rapidement par
le Conseil
mais qui doit aussi avoir la validation
comme c'est inscrit dans les
institutions européennes du Parlement et
pour ça il faut que ça soit le document
de la Commission doit être instruit par
la commission INTA et j'en deviens le
rapporteur très rapidement je me rends
compte que ce dossier est pose
énormément de problèmes on pourra
rentrer dans le détail si ça vous
intéresse après à la fois sur la
question de l'agriculture au Maroc sur
le fait que ça risque de poser
énormément de problèmes à la majorité
des paysans marocains
premier élément ça va poser des
problèmes sur l'utilisation des nappes
phréatiques et on voit bien aujourd'hui
ce qu'il en est pas simplement
malheureusement au Maroc mais partout à
travers la planète ça va poser un
problème social pour les producteurs
européens de fruits et légumes et ce qui
va entraîner leur mobilisation toute
organisation syndicale
confondus aussi bien en Italie en
Espagne qu'en France puisque j'aurais
même le soutien des producteurs légumes
de la FNSEA ce qui a priori n'était pas
quelque chose d'évident vu mon passé que
vous avez rappelé mais en tout cas on a
travaillé ensemble à ce moment-là et ça
va
amener un certain nombre de discussions
donc cette question agricole cette
question de l'eau cette question donc
des territoires européens et des
producteurs de fruits et légumes qui
vont être marqués
ça va poser un problème économique parce
que je me rends compte en rentrant dans
le dossier que seulement trois
entreprises au niveau d'européenne et
une Marocaine marocaine c'est le domaine
royal et pour l'Europe ce sont deux
entreprises françaises une qui s'appelle
Azura qui est basé à Château renard et
une autre idylle qui est basée à
Perpignan ces trois entreprises à elle
seule représente plus de 70% du marché
des exportations du Maroc donc on est là
sur un problème économique c'est le
point ensuite se pose évidemment la
question sociale des paysans impactés et
de la
distorsion de concurrence du côté
européen et ensuite on se retrouve sur
un point
qui au départ pour moi
n'était pas rentré dans cette discussion
mais quand je regarde et que je lis
l'accord en entier rien n'est dit sur le
territoire du Sahara occidental qui lui
se retrouve
rattachée et administrer de fait des
facto par le Maroc
et alors qu'en réalité
ce territoire est inscrit au niveau des
Nations unies dans le cadre des
territoires non autonomes et donc se
pose évidemment le problème de savoir si
dans cet accord
ce territoire non autonome
et géographiquement inscrit ce que ne
dit pas le texte à partir de là je
demande à la fois au Parlement et à la
Commission de vérifier ces éléments et
il faudra attendre un certain nombre de
mois pour pouvoir avoir
une réponse mais qui est une réponse
ambiguë pas clair et qui suscite
effectivement des interrogations et qui
nécessitera ensuite un perfectionnement
dans le de la part des la commission
juridique et la Commission de l'Union
européenne et du conseil
pourquoi je me pose cette question c'est
pas pour une question politique mais
c'est bien pour une question de respect
du droit du commerce international parce
que quelques années avant en 2006 les
États-Unis ont passé un accord de
libre-échange avec le Maroc et le dans
cet accord et il y a une ligne très
claire séparant le Maroc avec une mine
tarifaire particulière et le Sahara
occidental avec une autre avec les fonds
versés directement à ce territoire non
autonome or dans le texte européen rien
n'est inscrit et la personne qui inscrit
cela parce qu'il répond à une question
sur cette sur ce sujet devant le Congrès
des États-Unis s'appelle Robert Zellik
et c'est le
ministre du Commerce
international auprès de Monsieur bouche
il s'appelle donc Monsieur Robert Zellik
et c'est lui qui devant le Congrès dit
très clairement on ne peut pas traiter
de la même manière un État souverain et
un territoire non autonome et donc la
question que je pose aux autorités
européennes et au juristes c'est bien de
savoir si effectivement cette question
peut-être
tranchée de manière juridique
plusieurs mois se passent entre temps le
conseil à adopter lui le texte et donc
il n'y a que le Parlement qui n'a
toujours pas
accompli le vote ni devant la commission
INTA ni en plénière
suite à cela et aux ambiguïtés et au
tergiversations juridique de la
Commission et des services juridiques du
Parlement je propose
de saisir directement la Cour de justice
de l'Union européenne pour faire dire le
droit c'est quelque chose qui est prévu
au niveau des institutions européennes
qu'en cas d'interprétation qui serait à
multiples réponses il est prévu dans les
textes que une commission du Parlement
européen saisissent la présidence et
qu'on vote la saisine de la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne
j'ai eu un refus global de l'institution
d'abord de président de la commission
INTA puis
un ensemble de blocages qui fait que on
n'a pas pu comme je le souhaitais saisir
la Cour de justice de l'Union européenne
les mois avançant on arrive en 2002 et
là les pressions se renforcent d'abord
de la part du de l'ambassadeur du Maroc
auprès de l'Union européenne qui vient
me rencontrer c'est monsieur ménoir
halemme qui vient essayer de me
convaincre puis ensuite ça sera le
ministre de l'Agriculture avec la
conclusion que je vous ai donné tout à
l'heure puis ce sera ensuite le
l'ambassadeur de France auprès de
l'Union européenne qui lui aussi essaye
de me convaincre et Monsieur Philippe
Étienne et ce sera même jusqu'au
président de la FNSEA Monsieur Xavier
Belin qui est décédé depuis qui me dira
que soutenir les producteurs de fruits
et légumes vraiment c'est pas sérieux et
qu'il y a du business à la fois pour les
céréales les oléagineux et d'autres
productions agricoles dans le cadre de
cet accord et donc on se retrouve dans
une situation invraisemblable
ou ma demande précise c'est que ce texte
soit analysé pour voir si juridiquement
il est fondé je vous passe les épisodes
le et je vérifie bien ma date le 16
février 2012 le Parlement européen vote
en plein air et ce texte est adopté
malgré mes recommandations par 369 voix
pour
225 comptes et 31 abstention et donc le
dossier devrait s'arrêter là mais ce à
quoi je m'attendais arrive c'est que le
Front Polisario donc et leur
représentant reconnu par les Nations
Unies
décident d'attaquer devant la courte
justice de l'Union européenne et qu'à
deux reprises ce texte d'accord de
libre-échange est cassé et que la
dernière décision de la cour de gestion
de justice de l'Union européenne est
intervenu le mercredi 29 septembre 2021
et à nouveau casser ce texte qui met
dans un seul accord de territoires le
Maroc d'un côté et le sera occidental
cela aussi bien pour l'agriculture que
pour la pêche donc la question qui était
pour moi la question centrale du respect
du droit international dans un accord
libre-échange que je contestais sur le
fond mais cet accord aujourd'hui et donc
non appliqué et est entaché
dans sa version rédigée et votée par le
Parlement et le Conseil de manière
parfaitement scandaleuse et je dirais
que c'est ce qui a amené certainement
certaines autorités à vouloir me tordre
le bras pour m'obliger à accepter ce
texte voilà j'espère que j'ai été assez
clair et que j'ai respecté mon temps de
parole
alors au moment où c'est fait ce sont
produits on était au moment des vacances
puisque c'était la première fois où il
me propose un rendez-vous c'est le 15
juillet donc le Parlement
a fermé un ou deux jours après et c'est
une fois que les congés donc à la fin de
la session parlementaire qu'il m'a
rappelé sur mon portable et donc j'étais
chez moi puisqu'il y avait plus de
sessions avec le Parlement était fermé à
ce moment-là pour
me faire cette proposition que j'ai
évidemment refusé de la manière dont je
vous indiquais j'en ai parlé ensuite le
22 septembre à l'ambassadeur de France
auprès de l'Union européenne Monsieur
Philippe Étienne et puis j'en ai parlé
évidemment aux différents parlementaires
à la rentrée en septembre et les choses
en sont restées là et c'est j'ai rendu
la faire publique
même si j'en avais parlé à des
journalistes ici et là à Bruxelles mais
aucun n'avait repris l'information et
donc j'en ai reparlé et j'ai voulu
mettre des choses noires sur blanc comme
je voulais indiquer dans un livre qui
est paru en 2014 peut-être même fin 2013
et donc il faisait un bilan de mon
premier mandat de 2009 à 2014 mais le
problème qui se pose dans cette
affaire-là d'un gérance et c'est ça qui
la rend plus complexe
c'est que la France soutenait aussi
l'accord de libre-échange avec le Maroc
et que donc on était dans une situation
où effectivement les autorités
françaises voulaient que j'appuie le
dossier et en même temps les autorités
européennes et marocaines donc c'était
une situation tout à fait singulière ou
c'était pas simplement un pays étranger
qui voulait m'imposer
de changer de position mais bien
l'ensemble des personnes concernées ou
des institutions concernées
merci Monsieur le défi pour bien
comprendre ou surtout pour ne pas mal
comprendre laisser depuis cinq mois et
d'éviter tout malentendus ou
sous-entendu dans nos auditions parce
que ce sont des sujets très sensibles
quand vous dites que les autorités
françaises qui soutenaient cet accord
vous voulez aussi vous faire changer
d'avis vous n'avez par contre
contrairement à l'anecdote que vous avez
raconté sur France Inter avec les
autorités avec cette autorité marocaine
vous n'avez pas eu de tentatives de
pression des autorités françaises d'une
sorte similaire
non franchement à aucun moment
ni l'ambassadeur ni les personnes que
j'ai pu rencontrer
non ne m'ont dit attention
si vous changez pas de position ceci ou
cela Nîmes NAS ni contra ni rien non là
dessus il faut être quand même très très
clair c'était même pas d'ordre politique
parce qu'il pouvait pas faire grand
chose contre moi à ce moment-là de toute
façon et il me connaissait comme étant
général assez franc et quand j'avais
quelque chose à dire je le disais et je
l'argumentais donc à aucun moment
personne ne m'a ni menacé ni soudoyer ou
tenté de me soudoyer du côté français
bien évidemment
merci monsieur le député pour ces
précisions importantes quand vous avez
signé que vous en avez parlé à la
rentrée parlementaire à d'autres de vos
confrères et concerts et quel accueille
vous avez eu de leur part est-ce que
c'est occasion par exemple ils vont ils
vous ont indiqué de manière peut-être
anecdotique ou en passant mais qu'ils
avaient eux-mêmes eu des ce genre de
contact peut-être avec d'autres
puissances étrangères ou au contraire
ont-ils été étonné
faisant école faisant vous faisant
comprendre plutôt que vous étiez un cas
isolé parce que dans plusieurs enfin
dans un autre entretien à la presse vous
avez un moment parlé du fait que il y
avait des députés ils pouvaient exister
des députés le site véreux au sein
d'autres au sein du Parlement européen
ou peut-être ailleurs sous-entendant
peut-être que vous aviez connaissance
d'autres affaires ou pas d'ailleurs
c'est le cas de ma question c'est pour
bien préciser les choses est-ce que vous
avez eu lors de ce partage de de
d'expérience avec vos collègues après
après cet été là ou ensuite dans
d'autres moments de votre expérience de
parlementaire ou d'ailleurs de
syndicalistes et de responsables
politiques par ailleurs est-ce que vous
avez eu d'autres expériences d'autres
connaissances de tentatives d'ingérence
ou de corruption
alors je dirais que dans cette affaire
bien sûr j'en ai parlé à des députés qui
siégeait avec moi par exemple à la
commission
agricole du Parlement européen donc j'ai
été le membre dont j'étais membre
titulaire et vice-président pendant ce
premier mandat et que là effectivement
les gens n'ont pas été forcément étonnés
et ont compris ce que je disais
d'ailleurs ça c'était relaté dans le
vote de la commission de l'agriculture
du Parlement européen qui avait
majoritairement voté contre cet accord à
une très très large majorité donc de ce
côté là les choses étaient claires
j'avais observé mais maintenant c'est
quelque chose qui est connu puisque ça a
été dans la presse la façon tout à fait
curieuse dont
les amis de la reine l'association entre
guillemets en l'association de fait
puisque c'est pas institué d'amitié
entre l'Union européenne et le Maroc
accueilli avec beaucoup de plaisir
tous les l'ambassadeur les ministres les
uns après les autres et que avant le
vote dans la semaine plénière de
Strasbourg avant le vote de la corde
libre échange il y avait effectivement
énormément
d'élus ou de groupes de pression
marocains qui étaient présents pour
arriver à faire en sorte que le vote
c'est que ma recommandation de votre est
contre l'accord
ne puisse pas passer donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui depuis a été instruit
au niveau européen et reconnu avec un
certain nombre de personnalité qui ont
joué un rôle actif mais à l'époque les
choses ont été faites discrètement par
rapport à moi et à aucun moment aucun
député faisant partie de ce groupe ne
sont venus me voir pour me dire de
changer de position parce qu'il savait
tous que ça ne servirait à rien qu'à
partir du moment où j'avais entamé cette
discussion et ce bras de fer je ne
lâcherai pas
merci beaucoup dernière question avant
de passer la parole à Madame la
rapporteur je voudrais quand même
revenir sur ce qualiticatif de
députéreux parce que il se trouve que je
vous avais entendu en direct sur France
Inter quand vous êtes intervenu et quand
je l'ai relu l'échange je me suis dans
d'autres dans d'autres médias ce qui m'a
frappé c'est que alors c'est un
sentiment mais nous sommes des êtres
humains donc peut-être vous allez délire
mon sentiment le contredire c'est que
j'avais l'impression que vous n'étiez
pas surpris vraiment par le Karta agate
comme si par votre expérience ou par
votre analyse des choses vous aviez le
pressentiment la connaissance qui avait
d'autres d'autres circuits de
d'ingérence d'autres circuits de
corruption est-ce que effectivement
quand vous avez eu connaissance du
qatarget ça vous a créé une réminiscence
de de souvenirs ou est-ce que c'est moi
qui est
mal compris mal ressenti ce qui m'a
semblé est une absence de surprise
alors effectivement pour moi il y avait
aucune absence de surprise puisque
ce que j'avais vu du fonctionnement
comme c'est extérieur des députés qui
faisaient partie de
l'association au Maroc un certain nombre
d’ailleurs se vantaient ce qui est
d'ailleurs ont été ensuite pour certains
poursuivis en fait donc pas la justice
belge
se vanter très clairement d'aller
souvent au Maroc de recevoir
effectivement d'aller dans des hôtels
d'être accueillis vraiment comme des
chefs d'État ou en tout cas des
personnalités importantes et que tout ça
se faisait de manière assez incroyable
et donc tout à fait contraire à la
déontologie de ce que doit faire des
députés donc cela ils étaient mais
vraiment sans aucun filtre et disait les
choses comme si c'était normal et que
c'était c'était toujours ça de bon à
prendre alors j'ai jamais eu
connaissance à ce moment-là sauf depuis
maintenant sur les questions de valise
lié au quatargate et peut-être au Maroc
par contre les personnes qui ont été
mises en cause à ce moment-là ça ne m'a
pas surpris au vu de leur propos au sein
du Parlement européen je dirais que
c'est ça qui est un peu cocasse et je
regrette là aussi qu'aujourd'hui malgré
les grandes déclarations de la
présidente du Parlement européen
malheureusement il y a très peu de
moyens qui ont été donnés et la
suppression de ces associations de fêtes
n'est toujours pas effective donc on a
toujours un risque effectivement que les
choses continuent et c'est ce qui m'a
appelé à témoigner sur France Inter le
16 décembre c'est parce que je sentais
qu'effectivement à ce moment-là les
choses n'avançaient pas vite dans une
autre affaire qui m'avait amené à saisir
à
accepter d'être entendu dans le cadre de
la justice belge
et ben à ce moment là dans une affaire
ou un commissaire européen avait été
injustement chasser de la commission
c'était le commissaire Dali qui était en
charge de
la consommation et de l'environnement
la justice belge avait suivi avec tenté
de mener une enquête comme elle l'a fait
pour le pour les ingérences étrangères
et là malheureusement
la police belge avait été coupée dans
son effort et n'avait pas pu aller
enquêter dans d'autres pays de l'Union
européenne donc là j'étais satisfait de
ce qui s'était passé au niveau de la
justice belge et donc c'est vrai que ce
que j'attends aujourd'hui des
institutions européennes c'est
effectivement qu'elles aillent beaucoup
plus loin pour qu'il y ait une
séparation claire et nette avec tous ces
lobbys d'État ou des lobbies privées
puisque malheureusement là aussi on le
sait d'expérience le lobbying a continué
et continue au niveau européen pour une
raison assez logique c'est que c'est le
lieu de pouvoir où se prennent des
grandes décisions sur en terme
d'environnement mais d'industrie
d'économie etc et donc effectivement les
lobbys sont tous là présent pour
défendre leurs intérêts mais de manière
tout à fait inacceptable
merci Monsieur bourré madame la
rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
monsieur Beauvais je vous remercie des
précisions que vous nous avez d'ores et
déjà apporté j'avoue que je n'ai pas lu
le livre que vous avez écrit
et qui est paru fin 2013 ou 2014 alors
peut-être vais-je être amené à vous
poser des questions dont les réponses
ont été d'ores et déjà apportées par vos
soins dans cet ouvrage mais je voulais
vous demander si
rétrospectivement
il
vous apparaît que d'autres
influences étrangères autre que celle
exercé par le Royaume du Maroc dont nous
venons de parler c'est à exercer
également par le Qatar et qui est très
je dirais bruyamment illustré parce
qu'on appelle le catargate est-ce que
vous avez souvenir d'autres réseaux
d'influence étrangères qui
se serait particulièrement activé de
manière plus ou moins
bruyante encore une fois visible au sein
des institutions européennes et tout
Parlement au sein du Parlement européen
alors là je vais vous répondre je vais
être franc
mon travail et ton principalement basé
dans le cadre de la commission de
l'agriculture et du commissions du
commerce international je suis resté
focalisé et comme j'avais énormément
d'affaires sur ces questions-là
que ce soit sur la question de l'agence
sanitaire des aliments que ça soit sur
la question du lobby du tabac etc etc
j'ai pas été à même à mener dans ce
cadre là à me retrouver une autre fois
face à des ingérences d'État et je n'ai
pas non plus donc constaté de moi-même
cette situation même si j'ai pu en
entendre parler mais ça ne vous pas
la la réalité concrète qu'on vit
personnellement donc moi j'en suis resté
à celui-là à ce cas précis parce que
j'ai été directement concerné et ça me
paraît effectivement le voilà c'est la
réalité que j'ai vécu et donc moi je ne
peux pas témoigner de ce que je n'ai pas
vécu ou de bruit qui aurait été rapporté
par les uns ou par les autres
merci c'est très clair
deuxième question vous avez vous-même
abordé les propositions qu'avaient
faites la présente du Parlement européen
Roberta metzella après les révélations
et le déclenchement de l'opération menée
par la police puis la justice belge dans
le cas de ce qu'on appelle le catargate
versus slash le marogate et commencer à
regretter si je vous ai bien compris si
vous avez bien compris que plusieurs de
ses propositions n'est pas encore vu le
jour où sembler déplorer une certaine
lenteur dans l'exécution de de ces
propositions de réforme de mise en place
peut-être d'un cadre déontologie d'un
cadre de transparence etc etc est-ce que
vous pouvez être un tout petit peu plus
précis à cet égard ce que vous avez fait
allusion au entre guillemets groupe
d'amitié mais y a-t-il d'autres
préconisations émises
par la présente mensuela que vous
pourriez vous-même souhaiter qui vous
semble être indispensable et que vous
souhaiteriez voir être mis en œuvre très
rapidement
alors je dirais que bon la première
c'était effectivement la suspension de
toutes ces associations qui sont
absolument inacceptables d'autant plus
inacceptable qu'il existe au sein du
Parlement européen des groupes alors ce
ne sont pas des commissions mais ce sont
des groupes de travail avec les
différents pays de l'Union européenne et
donc les relations doivent se faire dans
ce cadre-là de parlementaire à
parlementaire ou dans le cadre de visite
mais qui sont organisés par les
institutions européennes et les
invitations sont toujours
les disons les frais sont pris en charge
par l'institution européenne dans un
cadre très précis et là je crois qu'il
faut être absolument intransigeant et
qu'il faudrait être beaucoup plus
vigilant de manière très claire
sur la question la déontologie des
députés forcer de constater et je les
constaté pendant les 10 ans j'ai siéger
au Parlement européen que la déontologie
sur les sur les contes des députés ou
sur l'utilisation des fonds qui sont
alloués au députés le moins ce qu'on
puisse dire c'est qu'il n'y a qu'un
contrôle aléatoire et très limité et que
par exemple je ne connais jamais connu
quelqu'un qui avait été l'objet d'un de
ces contrôles donc ça ça pose
effectivement un problème
pareil pour le patrimoine le patrimoine
du député
[Musique]
que sur une déclaration que le député
fait lui-même et donc il n'y a pas de
vérification
contrairement
à l'Assemblée nationale ou même en
France en général ou moi-même en tant
que dép européen au même titre que les
autres
parlementaires français on est tenu
effectivement de justifier son
patrimoine tous les ans et d'expliquer
pourquoi telsome ou telle somme ou
pourquoi tel dépense ou tel des bottes
et ça me paraît que tout à fait normal
et légitime dans la mesure où on doit
rendre des comptes aux citoyens
français et de l'Union européenne donc
de ce côté là et là malheureusement on
n'a aucune avancée sérieuse quand elle
est déontologie propre
là aussi il manque très clairement un
groupe de travail
institutionnel qui serait dans le cadre
du Parlement européen avec des élus
nommés qui suivent vraiment la
déontologie et qu'on puisse faire des
rappels à l'ordre on a souffert
pendant des années même si des choses
ont un petit peu changé
de ce problème au niveau de la
Commission européenne où le nombre de
fois on s'est retrouvé en situation
invraisemblable de lobbying à travers
les gens qui étaient soi-disant chargés
et je souviens de Monsieur le petit qui
était avocat qui travaillait à la fois
pour des groupes de pression économiques
le lobbyte là-bas et qui était chargé en
même temps de faire de présider la
commission de déontologie de la
Commission européenne ce qui était quand
même un paradoxe on est arrivé malgré
cela à le à le faire chasser à ce qui ne
puisse plus être dans cette institution
donc voilà mais donc pour ça il faut
être très précis avancé et être
rigoureux et absolument sans aucune
faille
merci Monsieur Beauvais je laisse la
parole aux vice-présidents Dumont
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Beauvais merci beaucoup de votre
présence parmi nous j'ai plusieurs
questions je propose peut-être de
les faire au fur et à mesure vous
laisser répondre et peut-être que je
puisse rebondir
question pour bien avoir compris vous
avez expliqué lors de votre propos
introductif que
il n'y a pas eu de plainte qui a été
déposé contre vous malgré une sorte de
menace de porte d'un dépôt de plainte
est-ce que ça vous ça vous est déjà
arrivé de menacer de porter plainte et
de le faire
alors non ça m'arrive jamais parce que
si je suis attaqué
dans la presse
si c'est un propos politique je vais pas
répondre à un propos politique par une
plainte si c'est sur ma vie quelque
chose aurait été dit ou fait qui soit
contraire à la vérité mais encore il
fallut que ça se fasse j'aurais pu
éventuellement l'envisager mais ça ne
s'est jamais produit donc j'ai jamais
été en situation moi-même de porter
plainte ou d'avoir envie de le faire
mais cette justice existe et donc
j'assumerai si c'était le cas de le
faire si des propos inacceptables
étaient tenus
merci beaucoup
je sais que certains hommes politiques
avaient l'habitude dans le temps je ne
sais pas si ça continue à se faire de
dire qu'on porte plainte et on attend le
lendemain du jour fatidique des trois
mois pour poser la plainte en apportait
plainte mais on peut pas aller plus loin
parce que la date est fort close donc ça
ça a été un grand classique de gens qui
ont porté plainte mais pour surtout ne
pas vouloir aller au débat au tribunal
très bien je vous remercie vous nous
avez donc expliqué d'après vous la
tentative de corruption dont vous avez
été l'objet de la part de monsieur
arnouche qui était à l'époque ministre
de l'Agriculture du Royaume du Maroc
ce qu'on cherche à connaître dans cette
commission d'enquête c'est également la
frontière la limite entre
ingérence d'une part et influence
d'autre part
et vous avez d'ailleurs dit ensuite vous
avez utilisé l'expression chercher à me
convaincre mais chercher à convaincre
est-ce que ça doit être responsible
est-ce que vous avez en particulier une
preuve hormis ce que vous imaginez
qu'aurait pu être la rencontre chez
votre avocat que Monsieur arnouche
allait tenter de vous corrompre ou
est-ce que c'est une supputation
puisqu'il n'a plus donné suite à
l'échange à partir du moment où vous
avez expliqué vouloir le tenir cette
échange cette discussion dans les locaux
de votre avocat en présence d'une tierce
personne
alors ça sera c'est le genre de dépenses
classiques quand on dit à quel quand on
met en avant des faits comme cela qu'on
vous dit qu'on va vous amener un cadeau
j'imagine que c'était pas une glace mais
je serai pas de vous dire la nature
quand on sait ce qui s'est passé dans le
cadre de des associations d'amitié UE
Maroc ou autre on voit très bien de quoi
il est question
le fait que jamais je n'étais pas suivi
au moment où ce livre est paru que la
dernière demande de poursuite qui devait
intervenir à la fin du mois de décembre
la mi-décembre puisque les fêtes du 16
décembre ça n'est pas intervenu non plus
tout s'est fait ramener les uns après
les autres
malgré tout confirme la véracité de mes
propos mais ça reste ma vérité
est-ce qu'il fallait à ce moment là
que j'accepte un cadeau
et qu'ensuite je dis aux autorités
françaises voilà on vient de m'offrir un
cadeau est-ce qu'il fallait que je
prévienne
la justice ou le ministère intérieur en
disant on fait une souricière au
ministre d'un pays étranger
est-ce que j'aurais été vraiment écouté
et suivi ça ce sont toutes les questions
que je pose aujourd'hui mais que je me
suis posé à ce moment-là donc je crois
qu'il faut être sérieux par rapport à ça
on peut pas en même temps
voilà essayer d'avoir une vie publique
qui reste publique dénoncer ce qui nous
sommes inacceptables et en même temps
essayer de jouer à un jeu tout à fait
ambigu et donc effectivement j'ai
préféré ne me pas me mettre en position
de me retrouver en tête-à-tête avec
cette personne qui de plus maintenant
est première ministre donc elle peut
faire valoir tous ses droits et son
autorité mais en l'état tout la cause
elle ne l'a pas faite dans le temps
imparti donc voilà donc on est dans
cette situation où j'en reste à
ma parole que j'ai écrit que d'autres
ont traduites et que j'ai réitéré sur
France Inter merci beaucoup vous avez pu
évoquer votre rôle en tant que
rapporteur d'un accord de libre-échange
qui est précieux pour nous parlementaire
nationaux puisque beaucoup d'accords de
libre-échange quand ils sont mixtes
passent également par le parlement
national et j'en mémoire par exemple
l'accord du CETA qu'on avait dû examiner
lors de la précédente législature
est-ce que d'après vous vous estimez que
les
personnes en charge les députés
européens ou nationaux en charge
d'examiner qu'il soit rapporteur
commissaire ou même simples député
doivent s'abstenir de tout contact avec
le ou les pays concernés par les accords
de libre-échange et ce qui serait pas
possible par exemple dans un accord
France États-Unis pour une raison X ou Y
que il y a des contacts avec le député
avec l'ambassade des États-Unis pour
aussi comprendre un peu mieux les enjeux
ou est-ce qu'il faut avoir une frontière
hermétique absolument hermétique entre
les parlementaires nationaux ou
européens et les pays où le pays
concernés par l'accord de libre-échange
à partir du moment où s'inscrit dans des
débats démocratiques de et où les
parlementaires ou les responsables
politiques
sont amenés à débat d'un sujet c'est pas
possible de discuter d'un sujet sans
connaître la position des autres
personnes impliquées donc dans un accord
de libre-échange il va de soi que la
discussion doit se faire des deux côtés
avec des rencontres entre les
différentes parties ça va pour les élus
mais ça va aussi pour les organisations
syndicales qu'elles soient agricoles
ouvrières ou organisation les
organisations industrielles etc etc et
ensuite on juge un accord à partir de
son fondement et on essaye de comprendre
le mécanisme et en gros vers quoi il va
aboutir moi ça m'a amené notamment à
aller au Canada
sauf que à l'entrée du Canada alors
qu'il était député européen m'a empêché
de rentrer
parce que je venais rencontrer les
organisations agricoles et d'autres bon
ça a duré quelques heures comme le
premier ministre de l'époque Monsieur
Valls arrivait le lendemain ils ont
quand même été obligés de me mettre en
liberté et j'ai payé une caution pour
rester une semaine au Canada
néanmoins j'ai pu rentrer au Canada au
bout d'un certain temps aux États-Unis
je risque pas parce que depuis 2006 je
suis interdit de rentrer aux États-Unis
sur une décision à l'époque qui n'a
jamais été révoqué donc voilà c'est
c'est des réalités on peut se trouver
mais on a la même chose il y a des pays
avec qui c'est très compliqué comment
aller discuter avec la Chine d'un accord
si on peut pas rencontrer ni des
organisations syndicales ni des gens qui
sont victimes d'une répression en Chine
et on pourrait comme ça multiplier les
exemples donc moi je suis pour la
relation directe mais il faut qu'elle
soit franche et qui est pas d'ambiguïté
c'est pour ça que je trouve inacceptable
que des députés européens soient
aujourd'hui et en responsabilité de la
commission des des du groupe de travail
entre la Chine et l'Union européenne
soit interdit de séjour en Chine ça
c'est quelque chose d'inacceptable donc
je crois que là-dessus il faut rester le
plus transparent le plus ouvert et
rendre public que ça soit à l'oral ou à
l'écrit sur son site ou celui du
Parlement de l'ensemble des rencontres
qu'on peut avoir avec des représentants
de différents types des pays avec
lesquels on est en discussion merci
beaucoup j'ai encore deux questions
vous nous avez évoqué la question du
poids des lobbies d'ailleurs le
sous-titre du livre que vous nous aviez
présenté tout à l'heure
est-ce qu'il y a en quelque sorte des un
peu comme le cholestérol des bons et des
mauvais lobbys et où est-ce que vous
mettez la limite des syndicats comme
vous l'avez dit il y a pas de problème à
les rencontrer mais sont aussi une forme
de lobby en quelque sorte les syndicats
où est-ce que vous mettez cette limite
entre les lobbies qu'on peut rencontrer
qu'il est sain de rencontrer vous venez
de le dire et ce où il faudrait
s'abstenir de toute discussion toute
rencontre
la frontière pour il faut essayer de la
clarifier de la mettre claire je dirais
qu'il y a d'un côté
des intérêts
privés économiques des intérêts
économiques ou les ceux qui viennent les
défendre viennent parce que ils veulent
vendre leurs produits ou permettent de
continuer à le vendre là on est
typiquement dans des intérêts privés
ensuite il y a ce qu'on peut appeler des
intérêts généraux c'est-à-dire qui sont
des représentations d'une défense
globale de la société que ça soit par
exemple au niveau des droits humains que
ça soit sur la question
environnement que ça soit sur la
question climat et donc on peut très
simplement discuter mais on peut avoir
aussi des regroupements industriels qui
sont prêts à faire un pas dans une
direction pour essayer de bouger les
lignes on l'a vu même si c'était très
compliqué avec l'industrie automobile ça
quand même entraîné le diesel gate donc
il faut faire attention on a vu aussi le
rôle de certains
représentant des lobbies notamment des
produits
phytosanitaires donc des pesticides pour
parler simplement ou là ça a été une
bataille très difficile avec des groupes
comme le vôtre des
des commissions d'enquête ou certains
refusent de venir je pense à Monsanto
qui avait revenu refusé de venir à une
convocation du Parlement européen donc
on a énormément de situations de ce
type-là et la preuve que certains ne
veulent pas se montrer c'est que de plus
en plus maintenant de lobbies de grands
groupes au lieu d'arriver en tant que
tel et c'est prévu dans le cadre du
Parlement européen donc il y a pas
d'ambiguïté en fait se mettre sur le
couvert de cabinet d'avocats et où les
discussions avec les cabinets d'avocats
sont des discussions qui sont du domaine
privé et donc on ne peut pas en faire
état il y a même à l'intérieur du
Parlement européen et c'est très facile
de voir dans ce cas là si ce sont des
lobbys qui sont à l'oeuvre ou pas dès le
bices qui demandent que les réunions
aient lieu dans le cadre du Parlement
européen selon
les règles de shadam House qui sont des
règles du commerce et absolument pas des
des règles d'une enceinte parlementaire
et ça effectivement j'ai vu l'industrie
du tabac
proposé cela de manière tout à fait
incroyable par l'intermédiaire d'un
député qu'il est présenté qui les avait
amené au Parlement européen ce qui était
pour le moindre singulier c'était un
député suédois et la firme s'appelait
sweenich match qui vient d'être racheté
d'ailleurs depuis par Philippe Maurice
donc voilà chacun House dans l'enceinte
quand j'entends ce mot dans une enseigne
parlementaire là je dis scandale
démocratique ce n'est impossible donc
j'espère qu'elle Assemblée nationale que
je ne fréquente pas
les choses ainsi ne se passent jamais
parce que ça serait complètement
contraire la déontologie du Parlement
merci beaucoup et une dernière question
toujours sur la question des traités de
libre-échange de celui que vous aviez eu
à rapporter vous nous avez expliqué
avoir des doutes sur la question de la
légalité du traité en particulier ce qui
concerne le la question du territoire
non autonome du saharaox Central tel que
reconnu par l'ONU est-ce que lors de
votre carrière mais lors de vos mandats
de députés européens vous avez également
pu saisir comme vous l'avez évoqué la
Cour de justice de l'Union européenne ou
la présidence du Parlement sur des
possibilités de sortie d'autres
territoires non autonomes des
dispositifs de droit commun en
particulier la Nouvelle-Calédonie ou la
Polynésie française qui sont eux aussi
sous le même statut que le Sahara
Occidental selon les critères et les
règles de l'ONU ou est-ce que vous ne
l'avez fait que pour la question du
Sahara occidental
alors
c'est compliqué cette question là pas la
réponse mais la réalité c'est que
la Commission des Nations Unies sur les
territoires non autonomes prévoient que
à partir du moment elle est Nations
Unies déclare un territoire non autonome
c'est le pays
colonisateur ou qui est encore dans
cette colonie ou qu'il a quitte qui a la
responsabilité d'instruire l'ensemble du
dossier jusqu'à la décolonisation de ce
territoire des colonisations qui peut
être un référendum il y a différents
types de processus en fonction de cette
commission tous les ans se réunit et le
pays responsable doit répondre aux
questions et remplir un document et ce
document est publié par les Nations
unies
pour ce qui est par exemple de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie
quel que soit la position qu'on peut
avoir sur la question et je crois qu'on
doit connaître ma position ce territoire
la France
remplit devant les Nations Unies
l'ensemble de ces obligations de rendre
compte après le fait de rendre compte
suffit-il est-ce que les réponses
apportées par la France sont suffisantes
c'est une question dans le cas du Maroc
là on est dans une situation très
singulière on est à quelques mois
du décès
du général Franco et l'Espagne décide de
quitter le Sahara occidental en moins
d'un an et il laisse le sera accidentel
en plan
c'est le Maroc qu'il envahit avec sa
grande marche
et qui dit on est chez nous devant les
Nations Unies jusqu'à aujourd'hui
l'Espagne n'a jamais rempli et si vous
regardez le site jamais l'Espagne a
assumé sa responsabilités dans le choix
et dans le processus de décision du de
la population de son territoire pour
revenir dans les règles et on se
retrouve dans une situation
effectivement où le défacto du Maroc et
administré des facto est complètement
contraire aux droits international c'est
pour ça qu'on ne peut pas dans ce
cadre-là accepter un traitement qui soit
qui englobe ce territoire et c'est cela
que la Cour de justice de l'Union
européenne a dit dans son jugement de
septembre 21 la le dernier mais il avait
déjà dit deux fois avant et avec le
paradoxe que si le Maroc avait accepté
d'avoir un traitement différencié à
l'époque non seulement il y aurait pas
eu cette condamnation par la Cour de
justice de l'Union européenne donc ils
sont en train de faire appel évidemment
ils vont faire appel mais ça sera
recassé évidemment mais ça a donné deux
conséquences 1 le Maroc cet accord est
cassé et de le Front Polisario a été
reconnu comme interlocuteur pour la Cour
de justice européenne officiel du peuple
du sera occidental donc je dirais que
c'était une double bêtise si on avait
suivi ma façon de faire et qu'on allait
on serait en avant devant la course de
justice de l'Union européenne le texte
il aura été dit la même chose
c'est-à-dire que ce texte ne peut pas
être voté en l'état et qu'il fallait
amener comme on fait les États-Unis une
modification sur le traitement de cette
question et les choses seraient rentrées
même si j'étais en désaccord avec
l'accord même s'il était resté que sur
le Makor je trouve que c'est un mauvais
accord pour des questions agricoles etc
de souveraineté alimentaire tout ce
qu'on veut mais pour autant cet accord
aurait pu être mis en place or là je
dirais que l'entêtement du Maroc et la
non clairvoyance des institutions
européennes c'est quand même paradoxal
que ni la commission ni le Parlement ni
le conseil au niveau des instances
juridiques n'est pas dit effectivement
là on est sur un truc qui ne fonctionne
pas donc voilà
merci beaucoup
merci Monsieur Beauvais je laisse la
parole où il se présente
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Député mais je me suis
Beauvais merci en tout cas pour les
explications assez détaillées que vous
ne fournissez votre expertise sur les
sujets
je voudrais revenir j'ai deux questions
je voudrais revenir sur une question qui
a peut-être été déjà partiellement posé
mais qui me permet d'insister lors de
l'interview que vous avez eu à France
Info je pense fin 2022 vous avez dit
effectivement quand il y a des intérêts
économiques colossaux qui sont en jeu
des états font pression et certains
députés vers eux ont profité de ça je
voudrais revenir sur la deuxième partie
de la phrase
quand vous dites certains députés verrue
en profiter de ça qui visez-vous par ces
messages et vis-à-vis de notre
commission vous pouvez vous indiquer les
noms des personnes que vous vouliez
citer merci pour cette première question
je vous pose la question en suivant
après votre réponse
effectivement on a déjà abordé cette
question tout à l'heure mais je veux
bien y revenir il y a pas de souci
j'interdiens au moment du catergate et
de du Maroc gate et donc à ce moment-là
effectivement un certain nombre de
personnes participant à
au groupe d'amitié
le Maroc se retrouve effectivement dans
le collimateur et ce sont toujours mis
en avant comme quoi effectivement elle
bénéficiait de soutien de voyage etc etc
et donc on a vu que financièrement
semble-t-il d'après la décision de la
justice qui avait aussi des biens
financiers donc voilà quand je parle de
députéreux je ne cite pas une personne
parce que c'est pas moi qui fait
l'enquête et donc je prie personne là
maintenant le sac mais je dis
qu'effectivement il y a les gens verrues
parce que ils jouent de leur position au
Parlement européen et de ce flou qui a
permis à d'amitié d'exister pour avoir
des
comportements qui sont contraires à la
déontologie et qui amène effectivement
qui ait eu un certain nombre de gens qui
ont été poursuivis qui sont aujourd'hui
mis en examen ou en tout cas qui
pourraient l'être et certainement
d'autres aussi et donc à partir de là
effectivement c'est complètement là sont
complètement inacceptables
au vu des règles du Parlement européen
mais j'imagine la même chose serait la
même chose au niveau du Parlement
français si un député ou plusieurs
accepter effectivement d'avoir des
voyages payés par un pays étranger
d'être dans des hôtels de manière
éventuellement d'avoir d'autres
récompenses d'une autre nature et donc
voilà ce que j'évoquais dans cette
question là
merci pour votre réponse factuelle vous
évoquez également un club privé dans le
cadre d'associations d'amitié regroupant
des députés européens de toute tendance
politique avez-vous connaissance
d'informations relatives au travail de
l'association dialogue franco-russe
pouvez-vous aussi nous citer d'autres
associations membres de ce club merci
alors comme je le disais tout à l'heure
moi j'ai travaillé sur les sujets sur
lesquels j'étais j'avais déjà
largement assez de travail pour le faire
donc je n'ai jamais quand j'étais au
Parlement européen eu à me poser la
question sur cette groupe particulier
Europe Russie par contre au vu de la
pratique du groupe Maroc
que lui j'ai vu travailler j'aurais pu
très bien extrapolé et je m'en suis
souvent
entretenu avec d'autres députés y
compris avec des députés qui faisaient
partie de ces groupes pour leur dire que
je trouvais inacceptable que ce genre de
groupe d'amitié puisse exister c'est
qu'on serait dans la mesure où le cadre
du Parlement européen on a
institutionnellement des groupes
officiels de députés européens qui
rencontrent et qui peuvent se rendre
dans tel pays ou groupe de pays donc à
partir du moment cela existe mettre en
place ces groupes privés qui n'ont aucun
statut aucune légitimité et où les
députés n'ont pas rendre compte après
c'est quelque chose de parfaitement
inacceptable mais je dirais quel que
soit le pays quel que soit le type de
pays
très bien merci
monsieur le député moi j'aurai une
question complémentaire il y a un
élément que j'ai pas bien saisi par
rapport aux éléments que vous avez que
vous avez donné publiquement et puis
après vous avez parlé d'une journaliste
du Nouvel Observateur qui s'est
intéressé à cette affaire et à votre
livre si j'ai bien noté un an après sa
publication environ et vous avez
mentionné après une condamnation au
tribunal de Paris de celle journaliste
est-ce que vous pourriez préciser pour
quel objet elle a été condamné
exactement s'il vous plaît
alors
je ne l'ai jamais rencontré
et donc ce que je sais d'ailleurs c'est
ce qui est en filigrane dans le le
communiqué de presse de l'ambassade de
l'avocat du Maroc c'est cette personne
relatée ce que j'avais raconté de
manière peut-être plus précise j'ai pas
vu cet article en plus du Nouvel
Observateur donc certainement qu'elle a
dû employer des termes peut-être plus
précis en tout état de cause elle a été
poursuivie par le Maroc par Monsieur
akanouche et elle a été condamnée devant
le tribunal de Paris et donc c'est un
procès qui a été intenté par le ministre
de l'Agriculture du Maroc à l'époque
merci Monsieur
[Musique]
et que j'ai les signalé à de vos
collègues je ne suis incapable de dire
quelle serait la nature ni le montant ni
la forme de ce qu'on aurait pu me faire
comme cadeau
et donc je ne peux pas aller plus loin
donc je vais pas commencer à faire un
film
de
où je fantasmerai je ne sais quoi à
l'intérieur simplement pour moi la
question quelle que soit la nature que
ce soit un porte-clé ou un milieu
d'euros c'est toujours un cadeau et là
j'imagine que c'était pas un porte-clé
un ministre de l'Agriculture d'un du
Maroc ne va pas venir à Montpellier pour
m'amener un porte-clé de Marrakech
j'imagine
merci pour ces précisions et la prudence
aussi que vous utilisez pour bien pour
bien décrire ce qui est arrivé ce qui
permet de assez travaux de d'être
sérieux comme nous le voulons tous j'ai
comme une question sur cette affaire
parce que c'est quand même des choses
qui m'étonnent mais l'étonnement est un
sentiment courant en politique le
quand vous avez reparlé de cette affaire
récemment effectivement à l'époque des
faits il s'agit du ministre de
l'Agriculture à l'époque où vous
réitérez vous narez à nouveau ces faits
en décembre dernier il s'agit du
ministre du Premier ministre du d'une
grande nation alliée à mi de la France
vous confirmez si j'ai bien compris que
suite à cette intervention à la radio
une fois plus on avait été contacté par
aucune autorité française ni notre
diplomatie ni nos gouvernement ni nos
services de renseignement vous ne
serait-ce que pour établir l'effet les
vérifier ne serait-ce que peut-être pour
savoir si il y a une raison de mettre en
cause quand même
le Premier ministre d'une nation a mis
de la France publiquement j'avoue que je
m'étonne de l'absence de suite dans un
sens ou dans l'autre d'ailleurs des
révélations que vous avez faites
[Musique]
effectivement au mois de décembre à
l'oral sur une radio de de grandes
audience il y avait aucune ambiguïté
pour moi donc si effectivement les
autorités françaises avez-vous lu me
contacter soit le Quai d'Orsay soit je
ne sais quel ministère soit l'Élysée ou
autre il y avait aucun problème j'aurais
répondu
à et j'aurais discuté avec eux et on
aurait essayé de comprendre ce qui se
passait mais jamais je n'ai
effectivement mais je dirais que ça a
été
chaque fois que je me suis trouvé dans
une situation pas de ce type là mais
avec des relations difficiles avec un
pays tiers à aucun moment les autorités
ne m'ont
indiqué quoi que ce soit donc
effectivement j'ai travaillé avec
mes avocats et j'ai essayé chaque fois
de répondre de la meilleure manière qui
soit en rendant d'abord les choses
publiques parce que ce qui me paraît
très important quand on est face à une
situation de ce type là
c'est de mettre cela sur la place
publique et de ne pas les laisser comme
quelque chose
d'ambigu qu'on met dans un coin donc je
dirais que la transparence par rapport
aux relations qu'on peut avoir en tant
qu'élu avec des pays tiers mais je
dirais c'est pas qu'en tant que lui ça
peut être aussi en tant que syndicaliste
me paraît tout à fait fondamental dans
la déontologie
merci Monsieur Beauvais lors de nos
travaux depuis 5 mois c'est la deuxième
fois que le sujet du Sahara occidental
dans le débat français survient la
première fois c'était peut-être
l'avez-vous vu suivi dans le cadre des
révélations du consortium de journaliste
frankens stories et ils ont mis en cause
c'est à la justice en occuper donc pas
plus de commentaires le journaliste
Rachid embarkid BFM TV qui aurait ainsi
sur le conditionnel évidemment mis
diffusé un certain nombre de reportages
qu'aurait une fois plus été transmis par
par une officine
dans ces reportages il y avait notamment
un sujet
concernant le sarot occidental suite à
cette audition cette audition est
publique et les retransmices sur le site
de l'Assemblée nationale mais aussi sur
la chaîne Youtube
de LCP il y a cette vidéo a fait l'objet
d'une d'un nombre de visions très
important avec un record de commentaires
un nombre qui invite les commissaires
c'est ça les intéresse à regarder il y a
énormément de commentaires sur la
question du Sahara Occidental
est-ce que cette question de Sarah
occidental dans votre carrière politique
est-elle revenue est-ce que vous avez
perçu ou
compris connaissance de que le Maroc ou
c'est relais pouvait tenter d'influencer
le personnel politique français ou
d'autres relais d'opinion français sur
cette question du Sahara occidental
alors à titre personnel je n'ai
jamais été parti prenante
du combat du Sarah occidental même si
j'en ai compris
toutes les raisons et les et les faits
historiques qui m'amènent à dire
qu'effectivement
l'attitude d'abord l'Espagne puis
ensuite du Maroc sont inacceptables sur
le fond et sur le droit par rapport à
l'occupation et à la non possibilité
pour les habitants de ce territoire de
décider de même qu'elle serait leur
avenir et donc là il y a une faute
lourde endroit et en politique de la
part de ces deux états
je dirais que l'Union européenne de la
même manière par les agissements que
j'ai expliqué mais je dirais par
d'autres types de relations avec le
Maroc et dans la même situation alors je
veux pas m'immiscer dans la géopolitique
globale mais en tout état de cause et on
voit qu'il y a certains nombres de pays
européens je pense notamment à la Suède
qui eux sont très sensibles à cette
situation des droits fondamentaux des
peuples comme on peut l'être par rapport
au Wiggs par rapport au kanak ou par
rapport à d'autres peuples dont ou au
tibétain dont on peut décider
effectivement aujourd'hui ou certains
états décident de leur sort c'est un peu
ce que j'ai dit plusieurs fois à l'oral
quand on parle d'une gestion
administrative d'un territoire ou des
facto d'un territoire c'est comme si on
disait bah oui le Tibet est administré
des facto par la Chine donc circuler il
y a rien à voir le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est qu'il y a un vrai problème de
droit avec le ticket avec le Tibet par
rapport à la Chine et les Ouigours c'est
encore une autre débat donc non pour moi
je j'entends bien parce que c'est un cas
de figure très important d'un pays de
l'Union européenne l'Espagne qui n'a
jamais assumé ses responsabilités et qui
a gangrené cette situation et oui le
gouvernement
marocain la monarchie marocaine en font
depuis Mohammed VI quelque chose de non
discutable on impose un état de fait et
tout le monde doit l'accepter et toute
personne qui dit le contraire est un
ennemi du Maroc ce qui paraît
complètement inacceptable donc oui je
pense qu'on a il y a un vrai problème
aujourd'hui une épine dans le pied du
droit des peuples à disposer de même qui
est de l'autre côté de la rive
méditerranéenne et qui effectivement
doit être purgé mais doit être purgé en
droit et c'est ce que j'ai voulu faire à
partir du moment où l'opposition que
j'ai reçu au Parlement des institutions
européennes
a été telle que celui que je vous ai
expliqué je suis quand même en question
de me demander effectivement quelles
sont ses relations ambiguës qui font que
des commissions juridiques
d'institutions aussi importantes que la
Commission européenne ou le conseil ne
soit pas capable de dire le droit et
accepte l'ambiguïté des traitements donc
là effectivement on a une vraie question
à se poser mais la France est dans la
même situation l'État français c'est pas
simplement ce gouvernement si les
gouvernements précédents et j'aimerais
moi entendre pourquoi pas qu'à le
Parlement français se saisit aussi de
cette question sur la question du droit
or la question du droit la me paraît
tout à fait fondamental et le droit est
bafoué qu'on soit d'accord avec
le Maroc ou avec les représentants du
Front Polisario c'est même pas une
question de débat politique c'est une
question de droit international et
aujourd'hui
on pourrait prendre un autre exemple
beaucoup plus
actuel et récent c'est l'annexion de la
Crimée par la Russie on peut dire que la
Russie est administrée des facto que le
trimestre administré des factures par la
Russie est-ce que c'est acceptable ou
que ça soit la même chose pour les
quatre régions
occupées par l'armée russe non
évidemment c'est pas que c'est pas donc
là il faut que le droit et on ne peut
pas faire d'accord libre-échange on ne
peut pas avoir d'accord intern ationaux
si le droit fondamental est le droit des
peuples n'est pas respecté je crois que
c'est la base même du travail du
parlementaire de le révéler
merci Monsieur Beauvais dernière
question pour ma part vous avez
mentionné que vous avez été vous avez
des difficultés à pénétrer sur le
territoire canadien vous nous avez
signifié à cette occasion vous avez une
interdiction c'est qu'il est bien
compris de ces jours aux États-Unis j'en
déduis que donc vous avez tout le monde
sait que vous avez eu des combats
politiques et symboliques très fort
qu'on les partage ou non ils sont
clairement affichés bien connus il
relève de sujets qui peuvent d'ailleurs
être transnationaux sur la question des
OGM sur le statut de marchandises
ordinaire ou extraordinaire que sont les
biens agricoles bon certains nombre de
combats qui dépassent évidemment la
France et même le territoire européen
vous avez été aussi candidat à la
présidentielle en 2007 est-ce que dans
le cadre de cette candidature vous avez
été approchée par du fait de votre
audience médiatique au-delà d'ailleurs
du score que vous pouvez faire vous avez
sans doute comme d'autres personnes
politiques une audience supérieure
peut-être à la réalité électorale pour
des raisons que la science politique a
clairement identifié votre utile etc bon
bref donc vous n'êtes pas réductible au
score que puisse que peuvent faire les
écologistes donc dans le cadre de
l'audience que vous avez dans le dans
l'opinion publique française en tant que
candidat à la présidentielle en
particulier ce que vous avez été
contacté par des puissances étrangères
ou par des officines ou par des proxydes
ces puissances étrangères qu'elle soit
pour influencer modérer pour nuancer ou
portées des opinions
contraires ou autres
alors ça m'est arrivé à l'heure que ce
qui est déjà au Parlement européen au
tout début de mon mandat d'être
rapproché
par des personnes
que je ne connaissais pas et qui voulait
me proposer
d'aller en Russie faire des conférences
ces personnes qui faisaient transiter
soit disant du matériel médical depuis
la Belgique vers la Russie
on demandait à me rencontrer
ce que j'ai accepté dans un café en face
de la gare de Lyon en terrasse en
présence de mon assistant qui a d'abord
pris place à côté de cette personne et
une fois que les choses étaient claires
qui avaient pas de choses ambiguë je
suis venu à cette étape pour discuter
les choses ont dit duraient à peu près
10 minutes dans la mesure où on me
proposait
non pas d'aller débattre sur les
questions de souveraineté alimentaire ou
d'accord le libre-échange dans des
universités russes mais on m'a proposé
d'aller présenter ce que je pensais
devant les jeunesses poutiniennes
j'ai dit que en tant qu'élu il était
inacceptable comme le propose et deux
que évidemment je refusais et que même
si je n'avais pas été élu à ce moment-là
et simplement syndicaliste j'aurais
refusé de la même manière parce que là
aussi c'est une question je dirais de
n'était je ne vois pas et j'ai trouvé ça
parfaitement scandaleux qu'on demande à
un député européen d'aller faire des
conférences à aux jeunesse d'un
mouvement politique d'autant plus marqué
que c'était celui de Monsieur pudding
donc évidemment j'ai refusé et je n'ai
pas donné suite et je n'ai jamais été
recontacté je dirais que c'est la seule
fois où pendant les 10 ans où j'étais
par le mont européen mais même avant et
après on met fait de telles propositions
tout à fait singulière
merci est-ce que vous pouvez peut-être
apporter quelques précisions sur ces
existent évidemment sur cette rencontre
est-ce que vous avez la date
exacte ou est-ce que c'était avant ou
après des événements géopolitiques
importants qui ont concerné le régime
russe
est-ce que vous avez est-ce qu'ils ont
proposé une rémunération et autres
questions qui me vient à l'esprit est-ce
que danse de cette rencontre vous êtes
rendu et ce qui la réalité de leur
activité économique où c'était vraiment
une pure couverture
qui n'avait en fait rien à voir avec la
réalité de leur activité et est-ce que
ils ont dit est-ce que Alicia en leur
nom ou est-ce qu'ils ont fait comprendre
qu'ils avisé ou non du gouvernement
russe ou d'amis du régime
alors écoutez la discussion a été
relativement courte puisque j'ai donné
très clairement d'entrée un refus
catégorique d'aller porter devant les
jeunesses du parti de Monsieur Poutine
donc les choses étaient claires et sans
ambiguïté j'ai pas demandé leur cul
l'homme Vitez ils ont ils sont venus me
faire cette proposition j'imagine qu'ils
ont fait ça
avec l'accord de personnes certainement
en Russie et j'ai en aucun moment voulu
aller plus loin là aussi c'est pareil
qu'est-ce que j'aurais dû faire est-ce
qu'il aurait fallu que je lis j'accepte
que j'aille voir ensuite le Quai d'Orsay
qu'on mène une enquête non je crois que
dans ces cas-là la chose la plus
cohérente c'est d'être clair avec sa
propre logique politique et humaine et
refuser catégoriquement de rentrer je
l'exprime devant vous aujourd'hui parce
que ça me paraît important de le dire
devant une commission de de l'Assemblée
nationale parce qu'effectivement ce
genre de situation j'imagine que je suis
pas le seul à qui un pays totalitaire
peut faire ce genre de proposition et ça
je trouve ça inacceptable
merci Monsieur Beauvais non mais je me
précise qu'il y avait aucune aucune
forme de sous-entendu dans ma question
c'était vraiment pour avoir des
précisions et je ne me permettrai
absolument pas de vous dire ce que vous
auriez dû faire ou ne pas faire c'est
pas du tout le sens de ma question et je
vous remercie d'ailleurs à titre
personnel et pour ce que ça vaut je
trouve au contraire que vos témoignages
et courageux puisque dans le cadre comme
de chaque moine de commission nous
n'avons eu très peu de témoignages ou
demande d'audition donc s'il y a
d'autres élus qui ont été convoqués ou
d'autres responsables politiques enfin
d'autres personnalités qui auraient pu
avoir des éléments à signifiant de
commission ils ont été peu nombreux donc
c'est pour ça que vous avez été vous
avez auditionné c'est que vous avez eu
quoi qu'on pense de vos opinions
politiques et de nos divergences vous
avez vu le courage de les affirmer
publiquement et de les réaffirmer
aujourd'hui c'est quand même je pense
suffisamment rare pour être souligné
c'est Madame la rapporteur est-ce que
vous avez d'autres questions
c'est commissaire
écoutez monsieur Beauvais je vous
remercie une fois encore du temps que
vous avez accordé à notre commission
réponse que à la qualité et la sincérité
des réponses que vous avez apportées je
vous souhaite une bonne fin de journée
et nous suspendons nous avons l'audition
de Monsieur chaozer dans quelques
minutes vous pose de suspendre la séance
pour une pause réglementaire de 10
minutes et nous reprendrons nos travaux
à ce moment-là la séance est suspendue
merci encore monsieur
merci